attente en bouche bois qu'est ce que tu
fais de toutes les conneries ça m'aide à
passer le temps
encore une nuit de violences
certaines personnes n'hésitent pas à
dire que d'ici très peu de temps la
ville va étonner
ça y est vous avez votre compte alors
barré vous
je les trouvais le samaritain
le samaritain est mort depuis 25 ans
ouais c'est ce qu'on dit
tu penses que tu habites en face d'un
super héros va donc faire une thérapie
coûtent
se marre et un est mort hier
moi je récupère j'aurais par des vieux
trucs pour vivre
samaritain le toit les rues toi tes
affaires moi je m'occupe des miennes
ça va monsieur
pleine forme
vous êtes toujours aussi fort
non pas aussi fort qu'avant le corps
finit par ce bar et si tu en prends pas
soin
j'en prend plus soin depuis très
longtemps
pourquoi vous vous détestez
parce que pour certains il est trop tard
pour réparer les dégâts qu'ils ont fait
il cache quelque chose
cheveux qu'il meure
de rigoles
chose qu'on enterre viennent vous vantez
avait disparu
elle lieu petit cadeau
viola